you goons listen and you listen good i
don't give a flying [ __ ] flip about the
marketing reports we are losing consumer
attention they are bored to show we've
done everything we can on that front the
hell you have zayn the hell you
have
what you've done are worldwide
exclusives fancy transitions expensive
pre-recorded presentations fake live
events live live events and some gymshed
narrative garbage that didn't go
anywhere melissa data the data is clear
the industry analytics point to
fragmented attention in every consumer
focused vector but one and that is the
countdowns those ridiculous 30-minute
celebrity-soaked attention grab
countdowns before a company's actual
presentation actually starts actually
they are big dumb wasteful empty and
they work she's right i want to laugh of
course i'm [ __ ] right
so this year we're counting down
that's the focus the countdown it's all
about the countdown no holds barred
anything goes all stops pulled out of
where the [ __ ] stops are that people
keep pulling them out of yeah okay sure
but what are we counting down to like
what happens when we get to zero it
doesn't [ __ ] matter you can propose
to your mistress for all i care i just
want big number consumer eyeballs drying
out as they watch a marketing laden
countdown where we're drip feeding them
brand awareness and purchase intent
until they climax and their g fuel
soaked gamer chairs no not yet gross i'm
getting it though
so who do we have on deck to host this
thing i mean we need someone right
can we do a celebrity
can we get james van der beek team pacey
huh i'm just saying to the people a
giant [ __ ] robot with whoever the
[ __ ] we want inside of it hosting our
show inside of it hosting our show
i'm sorry what hold
we've designed developed and deployed a
wideband interlocal net modulated
telepresence experience through which a
virtual host can virtually host our
virtually hosted countdown broadcast
so what like a zoom call no no not like
a zoom margaret now
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that
what's up
[Music]
i noticed you stopped counting the
numbers
whatever is not a number my guy
let me see if we can get you some kind
of a break from the numerals match
my name's margaret shut up madge does
this
does this thing uh
i'm sorry
does this thing have access to the feeds
yes it has access to the feed all feeds
every the feeds on the planet hiking
even deep into trans local space with a
little extra juice you could even
transmit all the way sure yeah can it uh
can he
can he do trailers
yes
trailers number station feeds launch
codes replicant incept date satellite
destruct instructions suggestive tick
tock dances the basics it's also
equipped with the tricordal
thermonuclear essential masses placement
cannon
hot stuff uh give me the button
okay yeah sure whatever
what say you and i put the marketing
into the devolver digital marketing
countdown to marketing and give the fine
audience at home something
a video game
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hello
[Music]
so
[Music]
come here
[Music]
so
[Music]
no we didn't make that massive monster
made it yeah people are going to be
obsessed when it drops
well no not just the videos
we're the publisher
we publish the games that's important
stuff you know it's basically the same
thing as making the games without all
the you know effort creativity time
energy that goes into making said game
i think of us as a humanitarian service
like fema or crocs you guys see the
numbers that sheep game or whatever did
us a duper mad spike wild stuff really
wild stuff
it tastes like baby food
have you guys seen the numbers i know
right no you don't know
what do you know i know the numbers keep
going like this i'm gonna buy a house
what's going on is it working on the
[ __ ] moon
pre-sales engagement but these numbers
are like nothing we've ever seen
well that's good though right too good
nina these numbers are like nothing
anyone has seen something's wrong we
need to tell hazel this needs to stop
whoa whoa there's just crawl up all your
little horses take a breath make some
sense what i'm saying is that it doesn't
make sense it can't make sense according
to the tracking we're just you guys
[ __ ] with the numbers
no one's [ __ ] with anything we just
rolled a [ __ ] hot true what the holy
heck is going on with these numbers
what's at the end of 2001 with gigantic
jupiter space baby dave's all shriveled
up and computers going now it's like
beep boop
it's a weirdly specific amount of time i
wonder if
huh
kind of hope to trip
[Music]
no
[Music]
there's no comp in that that was an
accident holy but another engagement
spike the chat's going nuts so our
social media ratings and marketing
relevancy are shooting through the roof
somebody tell me what the [ __ ] is going
on moon house a [ __ ] house on the
moon what if it's it's the yeah yeah
that's great what if it's the yeah no
yeah what if it's the trailers
your big dumb robot uh do you think
[Music]
oh okay
yeah i was thinking something a little
more along the lines yeah
knew it let's
make sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah another massive spike like big time
massive what do the numbers look like
though they just just keep going up it's
absolutely insane this isn't real this
can't be real it's like some kind of
singularity
no
no it can't be did you just say video
game singularity oh my god wait what are
we talking about right now
video game singularity is a hypothetical
moment of absolute corporate convergence
an event horizon into which
kaleidoscopically manifold fractionated
conglomerate interests are inescapably
pulled and at a single point of infinite
density
compressed against the entropic
inevitability of like i don't
years of inter-industry corporate
mergers acquisitions between developers
publishers platform holders and soulless
holding companies
everyone buying merging with and
acquiring everyone else until the only
[ __ ] thing left anymore is one giant
thick throbbing ultraman omni company
eating up everything in its way it can't
be bargained with it can't be reasoned
with it doesn't feel pity or remorse or
fear and it absolutely will not stop
ever until everything is one thing and
that one thing is
everything and that thing is us
oh god oh jesus christ so two moon
houses you're not getting insane imagine
all platforms all iconic characters all
methods of monetization
all hot balled up into one monopolistic
origin of interactive video
entertainment imagine streaming your
favorite prequel as a service on on your
virtual phone while you're sitting on a
toilet in a in a metaverse taco bell
while you while you have sonic the
hedgehog in a committed non-monogamous
relationship with with that huge lady
from resident evil and they are they
could be playing apex fort zone on an
atari dream station 64. and it would all
be free to play or play the art
how did this happen
it's the mech
it's gotta be
it's the only thing powerful enough to
do it
you guys
you guys follow the directions right
oh of course
well
[Music]
once upon a time there was a plucky
squire named jott
jott roamed the land in search of
adventure
battling beasts
helping the helpless
[Music]
and generally being very heroic
but then one day he discovered something
rather curious
a world he never knew existed
i can't tell if it's just that these
games are amazing or if it's what the
[ __ ] happened to my shirt
what's going on
is this a singularity i just got sent a
review copy of metal gear cooking mama
mobile i don't even know what that means
do you even know what that means
the industry's folding in on itself dude
we'll do this call this call it slaps
real hard 10 out of 10. that's not the
point
chief you'll just put in an offer to buy
valve
microsoft bought bethesda again
just for fun just what the ever shooting
[ __ ] fire have you [ __ ] done now oh
um uh bucky squire we just did the
plucky squire thing yeah it was legit
the sauce to my robot what have you done
to my goddamn robot and what's with your
shirt it's the
so singularity is the problem
the video game singularity
somehow this big dumb whatever the [ __ ]
is channeling egregious amounts of hype
and marketing power into a single point
and everything is converging on that
point right here so what is the problem
soon devolver digital ink will become
the sole arbiter of all video games and
everything that goes along with it a
lone single mega platform with total an
unstoppable absolute command over
everything
so what is the problem
we don't know what we're doing
the devolver barely functions as a
marginally successful video game
publisher we can't be the
central ordinal nexus of all industry
why not
why
why are you getting this oh i get it
this is the uh
yeah
you can't
[Music]
jesus annapurna interactive just merged
with mountain dew [ __ ] they're gonna
make a soft drink out of journey
it's not gonna stop
the hype is too great it's the county
we made a countdown with nothing at the
end just to get viewers and built a
machine we don't understand to do the
counting down we were so preoccupied
with whether or not we could we didn't
stop to think if we should
we can't stop counting it can't even
stop itself counting this machine
is a mechanized construct of of
stuff
that's complicated it's off the rails
and it's just as stuck as we are so
no moon house
no
nothing
first it will be devolver then it will
be everything we won't even
what the
inversion actualized it's the mech the
freaking goran sits
it son of a snagging shad's butt
is it almost time are we almost ready
listen
listen you have to listen to me the only
way out of this is
[Applause]
[Music]
in the beginning
it is always dark
a single loot box coin
it is all that remains in my vast empire
[Music]
[Music]
video games can rise again
and you
and your dreams and wishes
[Music]
open your hands
[Music]
what are you going to wish for
[Music]
wakaranai
then there will be no more video games
[Music]
[Music]
as many anymore you want
and the more wishes you make
the more magnificent video games will
become
until
try it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
checkered
[Music]
totality
of corporate shame too many games
[Music]
dreams
[Music]
looms in my
mind
everything is one thing
that one thing is everything
[Music]
lose yourself in my eyes
[Music]
counting from now until we die
in time
sometimes
[Music]
[Music]
too many games
[Music]
beyond our wildest
dreams singular
[Music]
you